[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting you got your boys you got
your boy businessman and the boy can I'm
a businessman okay I got a button-up
this week the businessman and the boy I
button up the top button I mean business
back at it again okay we're gonna be
talking to each other today but we're
gonna be also talking to you and with
you because many of you submitted your
we didn't just go for questions we
actually went for your perspectives and
opinions on the subject of stress which
is something that we are currently
experiencing and instead of heightened
level yeah instead of going in seeking a
professionals help we are just turning
to you on the internet because that
seems I don't know it seems cheaper yeah
the interesting thing instead of
responses so it wasn't really efficient
but instead of going and paying a
professional like $200 an hour mm-hmm
again to get back to what we talked
about in the first ear biscuit which was
actually the lost episode we can get
them to give us professional medical
advice and actually get paid to do it by
monetizing our conversation oh we get
paid to take advice Yeah right I mean I
don't know that I would call it
professional beautiful a beautiful
arrangement no but seriously because you
guys are the the community the the herd
of mythical beasts that were also a part
of we can have a conversation
it was mostly I've been thinking a lot
about stress lately just because I know
we're both experiencing it yeah and I
mean I've been doing some things that
are like I don't think I've ever really
like addressed it addressed it well
mm-hmm
I do for some things but it was like
well wouldn't it be interesting to get
the mystic mythical beast perspective on
this and see and the answers that we got
some of the things that you guys do to
handle stress I think will be
entertaining and informative may be
applicable to us and
well two other mythical beasts I think
we're gonna have a good conversation I'm
certain that some of these techniques
are more healthy than the ones that I
employ so we can get into some of that
but you know it's the reason why such a
stressful time is because there's lots
of things going on but I mean we're not
complaining those things are very
exciting I mean tag blessed man hashtag
blessed link hashtag blessed hashtag
stressed and blessed I do think it is
always important to clarify that we're
not you know we we love our jobs that's
not what we're talking about it's just
we we we commit we commit we always we
say yes well right now even if you just
take yeah there's a lot of things going
on but I mean buddy system being the
main thing we're on the precipice of
beginning to shoot we're like finalizing
the scripts and I I wish we were closer
to finalizing the songs at this point
when we're like weeks it's not just days
away from actually starting the show so
I start when we as of recording this we
start to shoot Oh two weeks from Monday
and I just I wish you wouldn't have even
told me that that's news to you well I
think one of my coping mechanisms is not
knowing I lose I lose track of the tide
in the sand I'm just like I'm gonna do
what I can do as hard as I go as hard as
I can and it'll all work out well it
always has but it's very exciting to be
at this point but sometimes when it's
very exciting it's also very stressful
because we want this thing to be great
and I'm comparing where we are now with
season two a buddy system in terms of
like writing and preparation to where we
were with season 1 yeah and I feel like
last year we had we had completed
scripts and we were you know I was just
my main point of stress was like can I
own this am I gonna be able to act this
time I'm gonna be able to memorize and
act this stuff now we don't even have
something that I can I can study but you
but so that that kind of but you also
you also do know having done it for
season one that you can do it yeah if
that was an open question in season one
that's
there's no longer an open question but
it may I guess this is one of my stress
coping mechanisms is that I find myself
having to rationalize that to myself
it's like okay don't worry about that
aspect that's what you worried about
last year but then it all worked out and
you you know you you you demonstrated to
yourself that you could do it so but
that is literally the conversation that
I have with myself like every few days
because I go back to man last year we
were I was we were doing something
different I also think that you may have
a slightly incorrect view looking back
because mmm some things were further
along but I also remember I remember
very vividly like a month out from
shooting like telling Stevie who
executive produces along with us and
worries about a lot of a lot of the day
kind of all the details of who's doing
what and putting together the team and
that kind of thing telling her I do not
see how we're going to start in a month
like it that seems impossible and then I
remember last week so three weeks out
thinking there's absolutely said this
exact thing there is no way that we will
be shooting in three weeks and that's
what happened last year and then we did
start yeah I was like I'm sure it's
gonna slip you know what's gonna slip
but it didn't slip and it's not gonna
slip this time we will be shooting yeah
at a certain point it's just you just
start doing it you start shooting it you
start making it you you know it's nice
to have a schedule and even if it's
really aggressive or it feels over
aggressive you know you tend to you we
want to make things perfect as artists
but you know an artists work is never
done
you just run out of time well and I
think and then you just get on with it
and then it's okay and it's not the end
of the world it's the beginning of a new
flow you know blush last year I was
thinking about this we will talk about
this a little bit more but and whether
or not there's a connection here but I
think that my back went out because of
stress absolutely and at least that
hasn't happened because I'm kind of more
on top of that just physically the
things I'm doing to stay that off but
I also think that there is this I felt
so overwhelmed last year and once we
started shooting I actually we both
remember saying we had fun which I think
would is people to know is like typical
television shows the way that they they
work is you're writing and shooting kind
of in a pattern in a sequence and so
you're writing in the shooting starts
and usually the people who are acting
are not also writing it that's not
normal for television shows but because
of our schedules we have to do what's
called cross boarding or cross shooting
all eight episodes all at the same time
so so that everything is written so then
a producer into it so I can just explain
why we do that you may not understand so
because we have a short window of time
relatively speaking to everything else
that we do we've got to be as efficient
as possible both for our schedule but
also financially in order to squeeze as
much out of our budget and put as much
on screen as possible what we do is if
you have a location like a house where
we're gonna be living or whatever or
there's a hospital whatever you want to
shoot all your scenes at that location
all at the same time if there's an actor
that's coming in for that role you have
to shoot them two days in a row or try
to get all their scenes in one day
because you pay them by the day or more
like independent film so you're not
shooting it chronologically we may shoot
the last scene of the whole season first
we probably won't but it's completely
out of order yeah the way that we're
shooting if we if if we're if we happen
to be in a motorcycle I'm not saying we
will be but there might be a motor so
might be a motorcycle that we're on or
in or a combination of both kind of on
kind of kind of in a little bit of
behind and next - you don't want to you
don't want to rent that thing for a you
know for two months you want to rent
that thing for a couple of days so then
you find yourself shooting episode 8
episode 3 and episode for motorcycle
scenes it's like well oh no you got to
have blood on your face for this one you
got to change into this outfit you got a
changing now the Bloods got to be gone
and then you have to look at your script
and know what is my emotion and this
because the last time I wrote on the
motorcycle I was super happy and now I'm
super mad right
so you go down the street you're happy
good now you go down the street and
you're mad and you don't you that's why
blood helps it helps sometimes it helps
when you've been involved in kind of
leading the yeah the creative process
because it's not like we're just an
actor who's like I don't know why I'm
being mad now so I know I remember this
but I got it okay let's look at the
script I gotta get back to that place
but I mean we're not directing this
thing but as executive producers and
creators of it we're at this point right
now we're not just finalizing the script
in our in our voices but we're also
giving opinions on what that motorcycle
looks like or how much blood is gonna be
on my face at that point in the
motorcycle yeah and so there's a certain
divide and conquer so we don't all do
both things there's two of us we try to
take advantage of that and we also rely
a lot on Stevie and sometimes they'll be
like okay well I'll look at the schedule
and I see that we're doing right now
what's called tabling and that's not
table reading a script which is
something you may have seen in like a
BTS video but tabling is when you've got
a riders draft of the script and then we
sit in a room with our riders that were
working with and we all kind of as a
group finalize the script and it takes a
very quick pace it's about a day for an
episode which is faster than you
typically would go but we just don't
have time but then there's those other
little meetings like okay well what
should the motorcycle look like and what
should this costume look like and what
is your hair gonna look like and what is
your shirt gonna look like Stevie is
handling a lot of those decisions
because she's intimately involved with
the knowing where the creative is and
then if there's a specific questions you
may pull us out to answer but it's just
a little bit of a free-for-all and it's
a little bit more difficult because I'm
still on active dad Duty right because
Lily's in recovery from her back surgery
so your schedules kind of you know
Kristy and I are like handing off the
kids and who staying up all night for
medication purposes and all that type of
stuff so it's it's difficult for me
because there's certain points when I
have to check out of the process when I
really want to be involved and I can
only imagine that's more difficult on
you and you know I'll say right now I
appreciate you've stepped up you've done
the work of both of us because half the
time I physically can't be there or you
work on it because in it you know this
is the best time for the surgery but
there's never a great time for a surgery
like that right so I mean it's made it a
little bit more difficult and you know
when it comes to the songwriting process
like I stepped in when you were working
on something else and I'm like listening
to your demos and there's all these
surprises in there for me that typically
it would be much more collaborative and
maybe more fun but you know it's it was
nice to hear that it was done you know
and that it's good and that I think I've
got stuff for you that you're listening
to and then at a certain point we're
going to collaborate on these songs well
you know that's I think that's one so
again not I'm starting to sweat right
now not complaining it's so much fun I
love every aspect of it but I think that
this lead-up process is so stressful
because again but he says it's not the
only thing that we're doing there's
other aspects you know we're still
finalizing aspects of the book we're
still talking we still continue to run a
business and we're continuing to give
input on merch and that kind of thing
there's the ongoing things that we
always do at medical entertainment and
just involved in running a business and
wellsite know everything that's going on
on the this is mythical channel that
it's still getting off the ground we're
you know we're we have a great team
that's doing great stuff over there and
we're interfacing with them to like give
our two cents every now and again in
order to help steer the ship and you
know as good mythical morning is in in
like in the summer session right I'll
just make a quick plug go to go to this
is mythical channel make sure you
subscribe yeah and check out we got
videos coming out every day every day
over maybe more than one a day some days
yeah we've got you know every Friday we
got guest hosts on good mythical morning
and I'm those that that's that's going
great but it's and some of those guests
make videos on this is mythical channel
too so support the work that our great
mythical crew is doing over there in the
absence of more GMM episodes but um you
know there's all these moving parts like
well and I think you get to a point
where I mean sometimes I I think I had
an idea of what it was like to like work
on a movie or a TV show because our
point of reference for that growing up
in North Carolina as kids was
the DVD behind-the-scenes right yeah
because we didn't know anybody who was
involved in III had a distant cousin who
was an Oscar Mayer wiener commercial
okay that distant cousin that I never
met and that was what still bragged
about it oh we talked about it with
everybody I never met the guy but he was
at him when he was a kid he was an Oscar
Mayer wiener commercially dropped he
dropped the Wiener and a dog ate it or
something I don't know what it was what
a jerk
but that was mine but that was he was
supposed to drop yeah it was okay not a
jerk I don't maybe it wasn't brilliant
anyway but the DVD behind-the-scenes
like I remember seeing directors and
writers kind of home and on these very
specific details and spend all this time
on like and then we went to London and
we listened to the rain in London so we
would know what the rain would sound
like when we created it on a stage in
Burbank and then but that's high budget
film making right but when you get into
doing what we're doing and you're
squeezing everything so tight and you're
also doing all this other stuff it's
just like there won't be rain okay so
when we're going through the script it's
like rain we're like no rain
you cannot rain it's expensive cut
through that but the idea of being able
to just does rain then when we're
shooting then all of a sudden this
anyway rain oh you write it as
attractive it's in a different scene but
the idea of and I think hopefully one
day we'll be able to do this because I
think getting back to what I say in the
beginning I think the way that we work
and this leads to the stress in our
lives is we we see something that we
could do aa book I'll bring the podcast
back do a new channel take gmm to a
whole new level which is something we
haven't even talked about it's public
that we're GMM is going to be even
bigger and better in the fall but we
have talked about that doing buddy
sister I want to think about it at this
moment and I'm doing the tour we also
have to come up with all the creator for
the tour and then travel to 16 different
cities in the fall I mean you don't even
think about that but we keep saying yes
to things right and while we're having a
blast it could it's like piling things
onto this plate I'm hoping one day maybe
down the road
uh that we can be like alright hey let's
just do one thing let's just do one
thing at a time really well but right
now it's hard to say no it's really hard
to say no I mean we got asked beyond
that you know you shouldn't say the
specifics just because you just got it
no it's - oh no no it's totally
different you get asked to be on
something and then it's like like oh
that would help be amazing that's an
that's an easy yes and then we spend the
next 20 minutes convincing ourselves
that we have to say no it's like no no
is easy and the reason I said no was not
not just because of the time that it
would take to begin saying it but uh but
the thing i stoled you and Stevie in the
conversation was I don't think I can
emotionally handle right being taking
advantage of this opportunity to be on a
show that we can't talk about we
probably could but because I don't know
that we can we shouldn't because who
knows what they've done public with that
yeah so having to say no to that it was
just like emotionally I can't handle it
I think I'm think I'm doing pretty well
you seem to be doing well you you've had
oh I'm a pretender baby you've had know
what I'm saying
I've seen you be very very stressed out
you're not know how you can tell I know
how your stress manifests itself and you
know how mine does like mostly with
physical things and I don't I think okay
it's gonna be a crazy couple of weeks
it's gonna be a crazy couple of months
when we're shooting but I think it's
gonna be okay but I also think that we
can stop and think more strategically
about what is we're doing to manage yeah
the stress levels and I think it's one
of those things about it saying no to
stuff I'm skipping ahead here a little
bit but also the things that we say yes
to knowing that our lifestyle our
professional lifestyle is crazy but
there there's a mindset that I feel like
the thing I've been trying to do is
adjust my mindset to where every single
thing I'm working on is not life or
death I think for years
we I threw myself on everything creative
as if it was the most important thing
ever and I've had to adjust it's like
you know what
getting so worked up over that thing
that didn't happen wasn't worth it or
that thing that didn't go like I thought
or I didn't have enough time to add that
other harmony to that track or or get a
third take in that scene or I know that
episode of GMM could have been it has to
be the best one we've ever done like we
don't have a problem of having a
standard of excellence I think the
problem is having such a high standard
that it it gets your own mess it just
it's it drives me crazy so a lot of us
just a mindset it's like being being
cooler under pressure and not not
wigging out we're all over one of the
odorant wearing more like doubling up on
deodorant I think if I adjust my mindset
I don't have to I won't sweat as much I
don't need to double up on the DL role
but currently we both just wear
deodorant
we don't wear any first print you know
you know you're sure not wearing any
personally okay you've changed the
subject I'll go with this I I'm I'm yeah
I'm wearing just the owner yeah me too
and it's what had been sweating that
much I haven't seen your pits man I just
couldn't I just put this shirt on oh I
mean it feels Dana I said I was sweating
my back is sweating from talking about
all this this is a brand new shirt you
just put that one on so you could sell
it boil for safety that's a good-looking
shirt okay catchy so we are gonna get
into your advice to us or you just your
personal experience and then we're gonna
try to make it into advice for us but
first we are gonna take a short break
to let you know about this t-shirt that
I'm wearing that I put on so that you
would see it on my body it looks good
because I'm proud of my body but because
I'm proud of the shirt I love it when a
ridiculous concept from the show from
good mythical morning becomes in this
case a mug and a t-shirt something that
you can purchase in order to support
internat Ament the boiling I'm gonna get
out here and pose and really show it
what you talk about it alright if you'll
notice he's he's he can't resist rubbing
it that's it you know you know you got a
good shirt when you just can't resist
rubbing it for those of you who are
listening he just sneezed you heard that
we put something in rubbed it too hard
put something in the shirt that makes
you sneeze if you're if you're learning
dogs dander not true this is all learn
to anything don't buy this shirt not
true
that's all I'm not sure it's a 50 for
this one this officer is a 50/50 blend I
love a 50/50 blend because they hold
their shape a little bit better you know
saying a 50/50 blend you got to get a
little poly you got to get a little bit
of cotton and of course it goes without
saying the shirt is boiled for safety
yeah all available at Breitling comm
slash store along with some summer gear
we got some good mythical summer capsule
guys go over there and check it out oh
man you're you're gonna Beach it up in
in in full mythicality I won't go into
the details but check it out over there
we're gonna we're gonna hook you up well
reading comm slash store okay so what we
did is we prompted you to tell us how
you deal with stress we didn't ask you
to give us advice we didn't ask you hey
how do you do it but then what we were
hoping for is that oh we're gonna adopt
some of this stuff let's uh let's read
one Natasha Jennings says cornstarch
fire breathing helps me relieve stress
do it it okay corn starch fire breathing
the reason I wanted to bring this up is
because I have done this he's
potentially on my Instagram from way
back I don't know I feel like I would
have put this on my Instagram when I did
it but it was back in North Carolina and
it was at my brother and sister-in-laws
house cornstarch is flammable well I
don't know what I'm sure you guys can
tell us some of you science people can
tell us there is a phenomenon does it
called scientists when well science
people not a scientist means like II
like official but science people just
people who know things which is
basically every other person on the
internet there is a well no for real
though there's a phenomenon and it
happens you know how sometimes you'll
hear that there was like a silo with
wheat in it or a barn with wheat or some
sort of substance that has becomes very
part of particulate very small and
just gets in the air and then it blows
up it combust
it's a combustible thing when you get
very small things suspended in the air
they become incredibly combustible and
that is a scientific concept that's
called something that I'm sure you could
be looking it up but it's not even worth
it because they're looking it up and
they're figuring it out but that happens
with cornstarch and you can take corn
struck first of all highly dangerous do
not suggest doing this although Natasha
Jennings does it to relieve stress and I
did it at my brother-in-law's house and
it was pretty cool put it in my mouth
and then we blew it out like that into a
lighter and it just creates a huge
fireball you could probably die doing it
don't do it I'm just telling you that I
did it I didn't die and it relieves it
did I don't know if it relieve my stress
but that's what Natasha does and she's
not it's not magic in other words this
is a real concept this is something that
you can do a dust explosion is the rapid
combustion of fine particles this is
Wikipedia under the dust explosion entry
suspended in the air often but not
always in an enclosed location dust
explosions can occur where any dispersed
powdered combustible material is present
in high enough concentrations in the
atmosphere or other oxidizing gaseous
medium such as oxygen dust explosions
are frequent hazard in underground coal
mines grain elevators and other
industrial environments on the other
hand they're also commonly used by
special-effects artists filmmakers and
pyrotechnicians aka science people
aka Natasha jinx giving their
spectacular appearance and ability to
safely can to beacon safely contained
under certain carefully controlled
conditions well and it's safer than
putting again not an expert don't take
our advice we're just two dudes on the
Internet but if you put lighter fluid or
some crazy like combustible liquid in
your mouth
then there is the risk of it going back
upstream and in lighting what's inside
your mouth I'm sure that there's some
kind of circus performers who can do
that but if you do this particulate dust
explosion thing the chances of the thing
going back into your mouth is really
small because it's not in the same form
inside your mouth I mean there's a you
could also choke on it don't do it
why won't you be talking about I should
have brought it up there's Anna there's
a poster from World War one warning
about grain dust explosions prevent dust
explosions save lives save food save
property it doesn't say anywhere on that
poster reduce stress okay
but I think that the point is is that
doing something that makes you feel like
you're a fire-breathing dragon it is an
experience that probably releases some
endorphins which I'm sure has a good
effect on stress or at least puts things
in perspective yes I'm a dragon you know
I I'm a I got this big test coming up
but oh by the way I'm a fire-breathing
dragon right who gives a crap
right yeah I mean dragons don't need to
be educated they just fly around and
mete out justice on me well then you get
into a rationalization at least it's a
good life fail all right what else we
got
bloody grundle which if that is a if
that's a like an insult or if that means
sounds like an audition anywhere I got a
bloody grundle well you need to go to
the emergency room don't Google that I'm
not going to says karate chop pillow
stacks hmm
fat stacks of pillows being
karate-chopped I understand I totally
get it
you know you just got all this all this
pent-up aggression you don't want to
lash out at your kids or other loved
ones you don't have the kids no I mean
don't hit anybody I mean like verbally
okay but I mean just when things get
stressful you know it comes out sideways
in terms of like oh I might I might take
it out on somebody verbally and I'm not
saying noise I'm saying other people
yeah we don't do that as a kid I think I
might have mentioned this somewhere
along the internet path when I was a kid
I would get I would maybe it was like
puberty but I would just get real a B it
was people I get really angry maybe get
really stressed out my mom would say go
punch a pillow and I was right I would
literally do it we had this velour
pillow that was like it was squarish it
wasn't like a looser sleep on this
pillow this is like a lounge during the
day on a velour
ouch lose her sleep on it Villa you know
how you know their oblong and there it
was a decorative pillow I mean this is a
winning decorative pillows velour with
the fringe yeah and I would pummel the
crap out of that yeah velour stuff man I
remember I don't I was you know I don't
remember much about my my puberty days
because your brain is disengaged but
attached it's actually completely
detached it's like there's no brain
connection I look at a brain going
through puberty you go in there and it's
attached to nothing right is for loading
the brainstem is detached completely
like the matrix all your body's blood
flow is going to other places to like
grow pubes and via armpit hair and stuff
right yeah so you got a lot of blood to
grow pubes right farm now can't think I
can't think when that's happening you
gotta do your body's making a choice and
it's making it right yeah but I
distinctly really you don't even need
those I distinctly well I know you
talked about that well I was about to
Google I have my theories but do you
need pubes
not anymore don't talk about it you
needed them in the 80s we're talking
about
okay let's just keep going I don't know
I don't know what that means by the way
but I don't want to know yeah I know you
have something on the businessman I
don't want to know what that means but I
just think I remember the moment my mom
first told me to punch the velour pillow
yeah because I did it out of spite
for my mom I was like oh yeah you think
that's funny I didn't say any of this in
my mind I was like oh yeah mom you think
it's funny telling me to punch a pillow
well you know what I'm gonna do it I
didn't say anything out loud she was
right though but I don't went over to
the pillow and I started punching it and
then I realized she was right yeah it
worked it tell it works well I mean and
he said a stack of pillows which a get
or she bloody groan doll is even better
because I also remember punching so hard
that hit the floor you know one Taylor
Ray felts which also sounds like a
sentence says definitely the best stress
reliever for me is either taking a
baseball bat to a couch or hitting rocks
with one so a baseball to a couch yet a
baseball bat
so the
I mean again all of this is somewhat
scientific but this is we and this is
one of the reasons that we're so
stressed out in this culture is because
if you go back hundreds of thousands of
years right or a lot of political exerts
even if you go back just in some places
a few hundred years or definitely a few
thousand years we were doing what we
were right in soil fighting for our next
meal no I'm saying pre agriculture so go
back react ten thousand years got to
hunter-gatherer days survival and you're
basically just trying to survive you're
trying to get to your next meal you're
fighting over a lot of resources there's
lots of death in the same well and you
can look at the animal kingdom which is
very informative to us as our cousins
and you can look at them and you can say
well they have this this stress response
that builds up and then they exert the
stress and but they have this cortisol
buildup in their in their system and
then they exert it but we don't do that
we just build up we build up those
hormones and then we haven't we don't
exert them we put them into into our
work which it doesn't release them in
the same way like a gorilla snapping a
giraffe neck yeah
gorillas are vegetarians they don't go
after address but I've seen him ride one
I'm sure they could but this would be
like taking that pillow is like an
antelope yes you know what I mean nap is
now you got to snap that antelopes neck
but you would be doing that like a
couple of times a week back in the day
which explains why I then proceeded to
eat the pillow right yeah and the velour
is a lot like an antelope pelt yeah it's
all very tight together and very
scientific but it totally makes sense
and that's why exercise is so helpful
but it's also why they have that one of
those rage rooms I don't know what they
call them but we talked about this on
GMM a while back where they had I think
we did they have these rooms that you
can pay to go in and they give you like
a bath or an axe and you just beat the
living crap out of everything in that
room and it makes you feel better
because you get to you get to destroy
things in some senses we were created to
destroy we're like we're made to destroy
stuff and you got you that might just be
like lifting a weight it might just be
like yelling it might be hitting a
pillow anger
anger room dot-com this is in Los
Angeles right let's go angry man anger
room TM their tagline is nothing you
expect everything you deserve you
deserve to just go in there and be
something about us let me click on this
is a company started back in 2008
provides an alternative to seeing a head
doctor or talking it out when you're
having a bad day I just say I I wouldn't
say an alternative those are great
things to do I would just call this a
cool supplement well I bet there are
some people who don't need this we
believe that sometimes it's better to
just do what you feel and lash out when
you need to I'm not agreeing with their
about us I'm agreeing with what they've
got but I'm not agreeing with their
rationalization for forgetting their but
we should do this though we should do it
you know what we all should do we should
do what Shelly Austin says while you're
on the internet if I'm stressing out at
home or at work listening to the rain at
rainy moot dot-com usually helps me find
peace not an ad haha so not an ad for us
either we're gonna send people over to
rainy mood what happens at rainy mood
all right I'm going helps you focus day
is there a sound sleep oh they're sound
it sounds like a it sounds like a rain
rain storm and it's different it says
today's music well today's storm I
immediately feel calmer I also feel like
I need to urinate what was it that the
whole back of their website is a bunch
of urine streaking out of a window man
as a rainy one
let's say - there in a second that's I'm
not I ask you just to sit in your
descent Mary hey you're that now trying
to sit in it I'm not kidding that's very
peaceful very peaceful ringing mood
Shelley Austin thanks for the tip you
can go to anger room or you can go to
Rainey moved hi I like rainy mood better
I got an Instagram feed that's just
pictures of rain and what more do you
need
the sound of rain to hear the rain yeah
but you can but they probably got you
pipe do videos is it videos yeah they do
that yeah all kinds of stuff related to
rain well that's good
what see now this is helpful we're
getting there how do I stop Stephanie
Renee Quinn I'm annoying and perfect
Quinn um when perfect Quinn demonio Ian
perfect she says I feel my car's gas
tank pick a road I haven't been on
before and just drive when you the first
time you said I I heard feel my car's
gas tank you could feel it like it's
covered with the rest of the car I just
feel a real but gas tank I fill my car's
gas tank pick a road I haven't been on
before and just drive fill out and drive
this sounds familiar
I mean we not only did this in our
younger days as fledgling automobile
errs but we also wrote about it
extensively in the book of mythicality
yeah because this wasn't something and
again we know we didn't relate it
distress directly but we relate well
interestingly us doing that and I'm not
gonna give it away because I want you to
read the book to get the full story but
we tell of how this was such a ritual
for us in high school as soon as I got
my license yeah this kind of defined our
high school existence in a lot of ways
and it mirrors is this principle our
driving yeah it mirrors our approach
to all things creative even yeah I think
is I it wasn't like I always said let's
let's let's emulate driving in our
career but as we discovered in writing
the chapter that's really that that's
that's it's what happened yeah so we
talked about that until and explained
how it sort of informed our career and
how we think that this principle is
actually a tenant of mythicality so
that's in the book I can't run what
Chapter one of them there's 20 of them
book of mythicality calm but you know
and and and music was also a big
component of that that we talked about
you know when we were in the car we
would we'd we'd play certain tracks of
music and we'd get into it that's
something that I do now if I have if I'm
more stressed I actually won't listen to
a podcast in the car which I do very
frequently I'll listen to music and it's
it's not in the way you would expect
like the stress relief of music for me
is that is not first and foremost that
it is directly relaxing it's do it it's
directly a distraction because most of
them when I listen to music especially
new music that I haven't heard before I
very quickly get I just it takes 100% of
my attention well not when I'm driving
it takes everything except my driving
attention at least 2 percent should like
a road I to analyze it I don't know I
don't listen to music is like like
listening to that rain it's like it
gives me something like I can just pour
my analytics into instead of pouring it
like directing it toward my anxiety like
the thing I'm anxious about I can think
in in cycles and circles and just in and
it'll spiral out of control and I'll
just get really worked up instead I'll
listen to music you know and I'll break
it down in my mind and that's really
helpful for me well alright well you
can't mean it's not the only problem
with that I mean you got a leaves not
relaxing you got to leave room for a spa
radio man I told you about that you
mention it I forgot I never tried so
sometimes it's real real bad and
sometimes it's real real
is this is like this is not google play
music or Spotify so this is Apple spa
radio okay so again
and this is actually this is probably my
number one most reliable source of
stress relief on any only given but not
spot radio the particular but spot radio
is part of it so we're talking like
every Saturday like Chinese flute you
know sometimes I got Chinese flute
sometimes it's sometimes it's just rain
sometimes it's more electronic sometimes
it's like weird sitar zand stuff again I
told you it's like I got a frickin
temple up there and just broadcast it so
this is not in the car this is at the
home people are like is there now is
there a temple in the neighborhood now
it looks like a house but well I'd go
outside and I lay down on the the patio
next to the pool in the great thing
about living in Southern California is
that for most of the year you can go out
there on a morning as soon as the Sun
comes up because the Sun is out most of
the time and it's usually warm enough
and I and I I'm gonna pair of shorts I'm
not nude I'm it just could just giving
you a visual here I'm in a pair of
shorts on a yoga mat and I have I have
like a series of exercises and stretches
they're basically yoga moves and then
like Pilates exercises and different
things that are all for my back but I do
them very slowly and methodically
meditatively basically and do some
meditation you know some breathing and
kind of focusing on my breathing while
listening really loud to the spa radio
and I'll be out there for like it's it's
like an hour of my time on the mornings
in the weekend
and especially as we have gotten so
every weekend you've you've been pretty
consistent with oh yeah yeah it's like
and I tell I tell Jesse I'm I really
need that time and because I do I'd also
do it every morning but just next I I
roll out of bed and then I'd again I
have like a 20 to 30 minutes of these
exercises I have to do or else my back
will just lock up because I'm a
herniated disc six that's phenomenal
so I you've done this for over a year
now
I'm very consistent done it for 10 years
but I only started doing the correct
exercises
since I went to my physical therapist
and she explained to me these are what
you this is what you've been doing
things that have been hurting you now
you're doing the right things yeah cuz
you like you said last year in prep for
buddy system your back went out not as
bad as it did that time before we went
on Conan four five years ago almost when
you were a sandwich
almost as bad but so you literally roll
out of bed onto the floor first thing
you do like you don't brush your teeth
you don't talk to nobody you don't look
at you brush my teeth you general okay
that's overrated
well I stress what's so stressful to
brush those teeth there's so many of
them it's a myth that you have to do
that you know I mean if I took that
advice my stress level will go down so
much you don't realize how much I stress
about my freaking teeth being dirty like
literally are you joking right now no
there are times when it's like my teeth
will feel dirty after I've eaten
something that and I don't mean
something caught in my tooth like a horn
of film yeah like a dirty film like a
dirty smell nasty tooth they call it and
until I until I brush my teeth I'm very
bothered
you're like a middle of the day brush
work I know but it's interesting because
I haven't gone that far
I typically it typically happens at
night like sometimes sometimes I'll
brush my teeth to make myself feel
better sometimes I'll take a shower to
make myself feel better but again not in
a shower the hotness of a shower relaxes
me or the steam it's the process of
feeling clean relaxes me I don't think
you know how to relax like you're
chilling like because because I've been
talking to Jesse so ups in our upstairs
bathroom there's a bathtub and then
there's a there's a shower and we only
use the bathtub for Barbara and I found
these things I found these walk-in steam
rooms that you can just it replace your
bathtub with a little steam room like a
one-person steam room I haven't looked
into cost or anything I just know that
they exist okay
and the idea of having a steam room that
I can just go and sit in not to get
clean but because the that when I go to
a spa and if I go into like the steam
room or going to the sauna like it's so
relaxing is that that is so relaxing to
me like
you're not using music you're just
analyzing the music you have to that
which is cool and great in a distraction
but you got to use music to relax you're
telling me that a hot shower doesn't
actually relax you you're just thinking
about like washing yourself in some like
pattern the whole time sometimes
sometimes I like what do you do to rely
on or Mille shower there are times when
I take a shower for the relaxing
relaxation now but what is your but
there's other times when I feel like I
feel so dirty now I can't go on until I
clean myself well there's nothing wrong
with theirs but I do anything right what
what do you like I said this has become
an indispensable part of my weekend at
this point like I have to have that time
mm-hmm and then I feel like centered
like in the times when I have been going
to the gym consistently on like Monday
Wednesday Friday I'll go there like 6:00
a.m. that's helped a lot and then on the
Tuesday and Thursday I'll still get up
at the same time like 5:30 in the
morning or maybe 6 if I want to pamper
myself get up a little later on those
two days and take an hour to just like
sit and be mindful of you know meditate
maybe take the dog out there a cup of
coffee but I quickly fall out of that
I'd do it for like one or two times and
then I fall out of it well it's tough to
make a routine but the thing that I try
to do is okay since that hasn't been
consistent for me I've tried to adopt
triggers like I talked about peeing
sitting down using one as a moment to
say all right I'm gonna this is a
reminder for me to just take a few
cleansing breaths just doing that on the
toilet not great like breathe really
deeply when you're in there but I do it
another time is my goodness you know the
on my on a fridge you've got the place
where like the ice and water dispenser
yeah I know that place well my my water
dispenser has like a hitch on it okay
and it was this gonna get to be relax it
won't it won't it won't present water it
won't
when I push it but what I learned was in
and I would like to start hitting it and
hit and hit it and try to force water
out of it like there's got to be some
hitch that I can feel something like
click a little later and then I realize
if I just if I take it and I push
against it in a way and wait huh after
like seven seconds all of a sudden
something will go and then the water
will start yeah it's like there's inning
it's like an old man and then yeah old
man waiting to pee and so now I've said
you know what I'm not going to get
frustrated at this moment I'm gonna now
use this as a gentle reminder to breathe
and think of nothing else dad why are
you why why have you Paul's definite
yeah look again for the water to present
once again like like a like a like a
somebody who's the battery ran out of a
rolling a brain like or androids having
a brain fart again no he's just waiting
for the water to present I'm I'm I'm
cleansing Lea breathing man no but I
think I think you're onto something I
think that the the principle of
mindfulness which is just something that
we had a you know growing up where we
grew up nobody talked about that it's
become much more of a of a thing in the
West now especially in Southern
California but I think one of the
reasons that it spins the idea of
mindfulness has been so appealing is
because we're just not good our culture
has changed so quickly and we're still
you know the way it's been said before
is that we are Stone Age hardware
running modern day software right so
we've got these bodies that are made as
a process of evolution over millions of
years got to this place where we we
haven't caught up with how much our
culture has changed and so we need to do
things that kind of mimic the whole
hunter-gatherer thing and the going out
and killing things and that kind of
thing we don't have that we just have
this very where in civilization and so
we need some other tools and mindfulness
is a great tool for kind of separating
yourself and realizing that you're not
your thoughts you're not this thing
things that are stressing you out the
things that are in your mind and the way
that you perceive those things it's all
just happening in your mind it's
actually not the thing that stresses you
out it's not currently happening but you
spend what ninety-nine percent of your
time worrying about things that are
never gonna happen
mm-hmm okay and so like dirt they're
interesting by the way I don't yeah that
reminds me of like I keep wanting to get
back into view zhing that headspace app
because that was so great and it's like
I do recommend that um but again I fell
out of it I think they're sponsoring
podcast now link oh they should sponsor
we should try to figure that out
have me so we just preemptively plugged
them yeah cuz but now we should even we
should try to make that happen with
headspace because we both have used the
app and loved it but I fell out of it
you know there's ways to get back into
it and one of those is make them a
sponsor yeah I don't worry about you
mentioned worrying about things that'll
never happen it's interesting because I
think so much maybe 90% of what I worry
about are the things that I do have
control over yet I severely questioned
my ability to to complete it or knock it
out of the park that's where I find most
of my stress you know I talked to
Christi I don't know it's like if he you
know I'll use lily surgery as an example
because it's such a stressful thing but
for me it's like I was so stressed out
about making the decision whether she
was going to have the surgery or not but
once we made the decision a lot of my
stress relieved because now it wasn't
somebody else's because I wasn't in
control over I wasn't gonna perform the
surgery myself yeah yeah I'm a little
offended no one asked but no you know I
think this is it I know where you're
going with this Jesse now we're talking
about this in the way that we are Jesse
doesn't get stressed out about the same
things that I get stressed out about but
like I tend to get very stressed out
when we have to travel especially when
have to travel with Jesse and the kids
mm-hmm and we have to get on a plane and
I get very stressed out about waking up
at the right time having all the stuff
that we need getting to the airport and
then I'm kinda
I'm a little neurotic about getting
through the security and then as soon as
we get through security yeah
my stress level goes way way down and
then when I'm on the plane and we're
taking off like no stress at all because
I was in control of getting my family
through all those checkpoints and and
getting everybody together and I take on
this responsibility because they don't
seem like like Jesse doesn't take it on
and she doesn't demonstrate a sense of
urgency in those moments so I kind of
take it on myself but then I know
Christy she's nervous when we're on the
plane and the pilot like she hears the
noise and she freaks out like once we're
on the plane like I don't she yeah the
pilots in control and he's either gonna
crash or not crash and there's nothing I
do about it and so I'm not gonna worry
about that but it's it's not some that
position that that we take in what
stresses out what well what doesn't
stress a choice it's not a choice engine
there's plenty of people that they're
most stressed out when control is
removed now the other thing what she
said earlier made me think about was you
know you told me I don't think you know
how to relax which it that resonated
from the script from what episode is
that 32 so three episode we moved in
episode 2 episode 3 cuz it was episode 2
I'm a million percent sure cuz I was
just in the writers room right before
that guy of a buddy system so it's funny
that everything we're talking about is
something that hopefully to success we
like we we make it into comedy right so
it's like you know these things that
we're talking about that I think we've
talked we've on and off we've certainly
talked about this and understanding how
we tick and the observation you made
about meaning me not being able to relax
literally something that rhymes that up
literally just with an hour ago I was in
there and we were reading through and I
was reading my lines out loud as we were
fine-tuning some things and I have a
line where I say you just got a fully
commit to the relaxation man I say that
in the script and I'm saying that right
now you gotta learn to relax
you gotta admit to the relaxation now
let's talk about some other things
because you said animal I got a quick
yeah so Monique said animal therapy
works every time Tillie Hendricks said
snuggle puppies or other animals this is
something that's new for us now that now
that I got Jade I ABS I make I make like
what's the word I an intentional
decision to grab the dog and pet the dog
to relieve stress of course well it's
great well she saw saw every single
morning when I Barbara sleeps in the bed
and then every single morning when I get
out of bed the first thing I do is I lay
on my back and I I've moved my legs I
put my knees in there and tabletop
position they call it and I and I rotate
my spine back and forth the legs going
from side to side as soon as I get on
the floor Barbara fart fart for a couple
times and then Barbara comes up and gets
on top of me she lays on top of me in a
very particular way she puts her each
foot on each side of me and she starts
licking my face and lays down completely
on me it's her spot she's like daddy's
doing his thing really I'm gonna do what
I do every morning and I'm gonna go lay
on top of him
that's good every single morning I'm
crying something about that made me cry
look at my eyes well it is touching it's
very touching that's so sweet
and and so you've been touched but you
also just took a drink of something so I
mean maybe you got some water right
through your glasses I was just trying
to drink from my eyes for once I'm not
all right but no but this is something
that I didn't have which again I know we
keep doing this but if there's one when
the when the touch point hits us we're
gonna we're gonna talk about it but
again because this journey getting to a
place where we have dogs was such a long
one and a circuitous route especially
for me and you know you had your in the
book in the book of mythicality
link talks about his experience with his
childhood dog I talked about my
experience with my childhood dogs and
then my adult dogs and all this crazy
stuff that's happened and then what led
to us getting Barbara and Jade and then
how they've impacted our lives and our
families
and how we think that interaction with
an animal is key is a one aspect of
mythicality so again that's in the book
of mythicality but we this is something
that's new and I know that's
significantly impacted and lowered my
stress level just having having Barbara
without a doubt she Jane has is look
like when you pet her she gets his look
on her face it's like oh that feels so
good but it's also like she looks like a
contented snoop dog I'm talking about
the rapper now like you know how
attendance that guy just looks so
laid-back I don't know why I don't know
what makes Snoop Dogg's so laid-back but
but I did once turned into a Doberman in
a in a yeah and in a video and she kind
of has a Doberman looks like it's yeah
he doesn't yet but like she'll get her
eyes will like go like this like they'll
narrow yeah dog it's like dog two dogs
eyes and they're all his eyes were
bright narrowed right now like I just
rubber right here he achieves that with
some other way snoop does I don't know
what it could be but for for Jade it's
like me rubbing right there and it
translates back to me like seeing her
talking about somebody on out I knew
that I wanted a dog right and was
talking about it you didn't even think
you want a dog the therapy like dog
therapy thing I I understood it in
principle I don't totally get it they
brought a dog in for Lily the first day
of her surgery they got like therapy
dogs running around and they put one in
the hospital bed with her a puppy no a
full-grown dog like a Great Dane no a
full-grown cazzo cocker spaniel big long
years floppy ears super soft super
content it makes a difference man and
again there's there's some reason why
that works okay
Chandra Hollins I think you'll be able
to relate to this I know I can when I'm
extremely stressed I write a detailed
list of all the things that are
stressing me out no matter how mine are
in blue pen then I take a sharpie and
write on top all the reasons why those
things don't need to stress me out then
I make another manageable looking list
of the things act that I actually need
to take care of so that I
have a handle on things lighting the
original list on fire offers additional
stress relief this sounds like something
that a therapist would tell you to do
and I will make I will take this
opportunity to say that's great
I mean that is great at going along
going going to a therapist or a
psychiatrist is absolutely splendid it's
not anything to be embarrassed about
I mean Christina I went to a therapist
just to talk out relational things
almost I wouldn't say it's not because
we have issues but just from a
pre-emptive standpoint I mean we have
the normal conflicts that couples have
and we've been married 17 years there's
nothing there's there's there's no
threat of you know anything undermining
our relationship you've got as an
external person to talk it's a health
thing but what I learned is that the
amount of stress that comes off whenever
you're able to say something and there's
a third person there to help you
articulate things it's it's a beautiful
thing and I can only imagine that that
also applies when you're you know you're
talking to a doctor of or a therapist or
whatever individually to relieve stress
or deal with whatever you're going
through it's it's it's magic yeah well
and everybody in this town it goes to a
therapist it's not when it was not
technically magic I should probably say
I don't think there's actual magic right
here you can go to a magic therapist
here that's called a it's called a
magician thank you thank you yeah I know
well I'm advocating therapy not psychics
but psyche psychiatric professional I
completely agree with that but back to
this but the list specifically okay so
this is something not this exact thing
that Shana has been doing but shout-out
to Josh Sundquist because I was watching
one of his videos friend of ours who is
who actually was here on your biscuits
he signed this table somewhere at some
point youtuber motivational speaker
author and he he talks about the
different things that he does every
single day
to help him manage stress see if I can
write there's four things I know one of
them was meditation one of them was
journaling and one of them was exercise
and then there was a fourth thing and
it's an acronym but sorry Josh I
forgotten it at this point it was really
good though and I wrote it down in my
journal did I say journal journal is one
of them maybe it's journal twice maybe
journals two times a day well we can
figure it out J for journal in for
meditation
efore exercise Oh germ reading germ J
journal e exercise our read and meditate
he wants to do all four of those things
every single day so we got it you know
what that's why he's a freaking
motivational speaker cuz you remembered
that yeah well you had to help me but so
I'm not misspelled germ I'm not Korea
don't bring that up I'm not great at
doing now all four of those things are
things that I really like to do and you
had to incorporate them to my life yeah
if it's a if I have a good week I've
done all four of those things it's
difficult for me at this point to do all
four in a day every single day but
specifically journaling so a lot of
people are talking about this bullet
journaling craze that's happening I
haven't heard about this so I'm and I'm
gonna I'm speaking out of school a
little bit but my really rudimentary
understanding of it is that you're
basically creating a journal where
you're recording your thoughts and
observations things you want to remember
and you are at the B there's a format to
it and at the beginning of the journal
you're basically creating like a system
of a table of contents that helps you
locate where the information is people
use lots of different systems so that
they then can go and access their
thoughts now I thought once once the
internet happened and once Google Docs
and Evernote happened I was like well
clearly this is a superior way than the
archaic writing with a hand yeah I mean
it's like my hand gets cramped and I got
bad bad handwriting and if you do it
digitally you can access it you can
search it you can search it so all those
are advantages but mounds and mounds of
research have suggested that retention
of information is way more effective
when you write things down then when you
type things out yeah and I've been doing
this for the fascinate for the past
couple of years but there's something
about
tactile interaction with something
literally there's something that happens
in your brain when you are you make the
letter may post a push make the letters
and you're you're creating a physical
expression of that idea that then is
stored in a part of your brain where
then you can associate it so and I wrote
down germ in my journal when I watch
this video that's ironic and so I've got
this system now that I have a journal
that I keep with me at work and I have
one that's at home and usually the one
at home is like I'll be reading a book
I'm reading a book by somebody I hope we
can have on the podcast someday Ryan
holiday eco is the enemy great book and
it's just chock-full of this information
that for years I would read a book and
then I would be like that's really
awesome
and then you kind of retain like a
kernel of that truth and you can kind of
remember it and keep it but now when I
read I take notes not in the book but in
my journal and that is a there's
something about taking the information
that I'm receiving especially when it's
like I'd like to read a lot of I don't
read a lot of fiction I like read a lot
of nonfiction especially fiction
nonfiction that see you can immediately
kind of apply to your life like the ego
is the enemy thing and I'll take notes
on it and then I find myself actually
remembering what each chapter main
points about each chapter so I recommend
journaling or bullet journaling if
you're gonna do the official way I don't
even know the official ways but people
people do science people do but the act
of another thing that I do in the
journal is if I'm stressed out about
something or if there's a worry if
there's something that's particularly
getting to me I act of writing it out is
a way of like feeling like okay I'm
defining it and I'm setting it aside and
I'm making it external it's almost like
I'm taking an example like what do you
do you write you write out what you're
stressed about or you write up you write
a to-do list I don't I mean I I do some
to-do lists like have you written
anything about buddy system yeah yeah
yeah so I would you right now I would
write like I feel like what we are doing
is impossible I
feel like what we have signed up to do
an amount of time is impossible and so I
write that down and it's just like I can
kind of like I think that was a text to
me and Stevie yeah I probably did that
as well and then I can I feel like I'm
removing it from my brain and putting it
in this journal and somehow it's just
like oh yeah it is impossible with it
but I also you burn it but that no I
don't burn anything but that's what
Chandra does I also write things like
but it's probably the case that feeling
like something is impossible means
you're doing exactly what you should be
doing because if you're not doing
something that makes you feel like
you're doing something impossible
if you're not doing something that you
think that you can't you're probably
doing something that isn't worth doing
at all you turn you turn stress and
there's something inside yeah and so you
it's like Casey Neistat says do what you
can't write and there's just something
incredibly therapeutic isn't that
systematic at all I mean it's not
prescribing anything in particular I'm
just saying that just making the
beginning the act of journaling has done
this first of all retention of things
that I want to know and apply to my life
has gone way up but also just this time
of actually thinking about what is it
stressing me out because there's a lot
of there's a lot of science that
suggests that you store stress and
tension in different places you know
that your muscles get crazy and there's
actually a whole school of thought that
you store certain kinds of emotions in
certain places I don't know I don't know
anything about that and and I don't know
if it's true or not but the idea that I
got all this tension for my stress that
I that I've put in my back yeah and then
my back is predisposed to injury because
I'm tight the idea of instead of just
thinking that I'm okay and letting that
attention be stored in my back if I take
it and I write it out I feel like
there's an act of releasing it and
defining it and saying it's out there I
know that I'm actually stressed out I've
admitted it but I also can kind of see
whether or not if it's even something I
should be worrying about because I
processed it I mean you would agree that
you don't think about putting on the
page you're literally not placing in
your back that sounds like that sounds
like magic well if you're saying I don't
see an indirect I don't
no but by putting it on the page you're
reducing stress that then doesn't build
up in your back yeah it's not I mean
it's not a magical well I think even
magic is ultimately scientific right I
think there are lots of things that we
don't understand about the world that I
think one way so that is what you're
saying the history of the past few
thousand years especially the last five
hundred is that everything that we
thought was magic turned out to be
something that we could define and
understand if we just kept kept at it
long enough and so but I don't mean I
just gave that explanation yeah but I'm
saying but it wouldn't be magic if that
is true if they find out that there's
something legitimately physically
happening when you do when somebody will
explain that at some point all I know is
that it seems to work for me
well it's something psychological is
happening and then it has a physical
benefit but there could be some energy
involved we don't know we don't
understand it all man
but I'm not gonna say one way or another
whether it's whether that's true
I'm just saying basically I'm just
saying thank you Josh Sundquist for
telling me to German every day it's
interesting when I the reason why I
don't journal is because I feel like a
journal becomes a record of how often I
don't journal and I can't get over it
the gaps you weren't about the gaps yeah
like for me it's like well I got to put
a date and then I got a lot of dates and
I got lots of gaps man but you keep
going back and it but it seems like a
defeat like when I go back say ah when I
go back I'm gonna see that date and
that's three months ago that was a year
ago you think of it like a like a
blogger from like yeah thousand seven
like it's it's it's so broken so I wish
there was another way I could do it I
can't get over that like the fact that
it's like if I don't do it every day I'm
a failure that's stupid
yeah because you care if you do it at
all am I trying to impress if you well
yeah I think I've said I'm sensing a
pattern here again I I think that this
is a little bit of a therapy session for
both of us take it but I think that when
you say I listen to music and the reason
I'm doing it is so I can analyze it it's
like well that's cool to just it's a
distress
and it's a hobby of yours it's a
distraction is it's like I'm not saying
that's bad but if you can't listen to
music to relax
you're then you're missing you're
missing a side of music journaling if
you're just thinking about the task of
journaling and the routine of journaling
and you're like I'm doing this because I
have to do it then you're because I've
committed to then you're missing the
point of it the point being that this is
actually it's therapeutic like I
literally you're not thinking about
yourself know when I've journaled in the
past I've thought about who's gonna read
it later like maybe when I die my kids
are gonna read well I definitely think
that that's why I say really poetic
things like maybe when you think you're
about to do something impossible you
know you're doing the right thing and
then I put a box around it and a star so
the historians will find it the
historians know I think Mike I mean my
kids are gonna read it at some point I
mean I'm sure people that makes me feel
better but that I know I'm not gonna
bury me with my journals man I don't
want anybody to see the mess that I
wrote you know I want that isn't that
impedes the epital point no I'm I'm very
honest in them and if if there's
something that I would be is is not
something that I would wouldn't want
read publicly cuz you know people could
find a journal at some point I just I
write about it in code you know in a way
that it's not you know the chief thing
on your mind is not an audience is not
the reader you know it's it's it's for
me
yeah it's something I need something
yeah and like that's what I have trouble
getting to I'm gonna need more link I
think citee side he said she relieves
stress by sleeping I remember once link
said how when he's anxious he's so
anxious in such which allows him to fall
asleep really flat fast
I remember when when Christy took her
pregnancy test and we found out that she
was pregnant with our first child Lily
what's her name Lily Lily the first
thing I said was I need to take a nap
it's like I was very happy that we were
having a baby because we were trying but
that's how I was like I just got a check
out a little bit because I'm I have the
gift of no matter how stressed I am I
can I can just fall asleep and but I
think that can be a problem because I I
think that that's escaping because we
feel like if you wake up you'll be
removed from the problem well and I feel
like you've actually done nothing when I
sleep I've escaped the problem but I
wake up and is still there I haven't I
haven't faced it or gone through and I
think that's something about mindfulness
or like writing something down or
talking about it with loved ones or a
professional or it's helpful because it
it helps you it there's not an element
of denial there's an element of okay
this is here it's like when you write it
down it's like alright I've written this
down here it is it's not me it's
separate from me I can do something
about it or I can have a perspective on
it that and and and move on or move
through it or at least begin to so I do
think it's you know like doing things to
to escape or erase it I mean you turn to
country radio and talk about you know
how to do that at the bottom of a bottle
you know oh this country radio country
radio
that's a bat-pole country radio they
romanticize you know drinking away
turning to so a lot of Merle songs about
scaping drinking it drinking away her
memory but you don't think there's it's
not hell there's an interesting
phenomenon that some people and I'm one
of them this is just never happens to my
wife you in the middle of a stress
stressful situation
you get really sleepy so not sleeping to
escape necessarily but oh yeah really
fatigued and like she just he never
relates to that but sometimes I'll just
be like I just want to sleep she's like
how could you be swung to sleep right
now are you freaking out about whatever
and I'm like no I just get really tired
I used to get super tired before high
school basketball games because
you know your body would get so worked
up it would be a physical thing I'd be
nervous not a baby I'd be pumped up for
this game and be nervous about my
performance and yeah I wouldn't be
jittery I would just be like I could so
take a nap right now
I like a 15-minute nap and I'd be like
ready but that is not the main thing I
do the main thing I do is this thing
that Bray Gotham does she says I know
this is crazy but I manage my stress by
cleaning the house for some reason it
soothes me and then I end up with a nice
clean place to relax it I absolutely
like you know when I came into the
office the other day the first thing I
did you were in there working and you
know I've spent the morning away and
then I came in and I felt late to the
game and like I was very anxious to get
going
first thing I did was turn the mats like
I was like that they moved us back into
our office and the the rug was upside
down the the tag was out like first
thing I saw an ad Grug no the the little
rug behind your desk that well first I
was like that rug doesn't go there but
it's okay to be there that was my way of
like not not giving it it's okay link
it's okay that it's there and then I
looked at the other one in front of the
fridge and it was upside down because
the tag on the rug was visible and I
turned that over enough and it's like I
instinctively start cleaning and
organizing like my my desktop of my
computer I went through stuff and I
realized that I started cleaning
cleaning that off and made me feel
better
well made me a sense of control there
was stuff from buddy system from last
year is actually an ultra mind it also
gives you a sense of progress you know
which yeah incidentally I can I I can do
this I can control something I can
organize something incidentally in in in
this book in in Ryan's book he goes the
enemy he has a he has a chapter about
how one of the tendencies that we have
is we substitute planning for doing
mm-hmm and so they're they're actually
people and this I'm just made me think
about this sometimes we think making a
list is progress
when all it is is making a list now
sometimes organizing and making a list
is actually it's it's I mean I even
though I'm not a clean freak I totally
relate to that like if I like spend a
day cleaning up the art closet or the
room or Justine I organize something
there's this feeling there's this like
there's an endorphin release without a
doubt there's a reward you feel good
about doing it that's I'm not advocating
against that but I'm saying that
sometimes especially when you're you're
doing what we do and sometimes you
you've got in anybody can play this
you've got some task ahead and you're
like okay well I'm gonna organize my
thoughts about that by breaking out a
whiteboard and making a list
studies show that I want to get this
right but people actually begin the more
you do it the more you do that the more
likely you are to begin confusing that
for progress and begin to think that I'm
making progress because I have a
whiteboard and I and I made a made a
list when you actually didn't do
anything and you can get to a place
where you feel like you're making all
this progress and all you've done is
planned for progress well I mean that
but as long as it but that I as long as
you cross things off the list I think if
if you make it making a list will make
you feel better and cleaning the house
will make me feel but then you gotta act
on the lip then you gotta cross things
off you have to act on the list and you
can't just cross them off you have to do
them first before you can crawl it you
know it did hell the whole idea of not
confusing a plan with progress that's a
thing that's pretty novel idea it's
interesting that I do not make lists
period I don't but you would think I
think people might guess that I'd be a
list maker because it seems the same as
cleaning but I don't know exactly why
but I don't make lists I Ted I feel
better if I just if I do the first thing
and then I like I get to a point where I
feel like okay the thing I was stressed
out about which is something that I had
to do which is maybe the top thing on a
list that I've never made I feel better
doing that but I've never made a list
that made me feel better and I think
that cleaning stuff or whatever your
coping mechanism as long as it's as long
as it's not harmful
is okay as long as you know why you're
doing it like I I don't think it's a big
problem that I clean in order to deal
with stress even though the stress is
not about things being dirty no wrong
with it as long as I know that like okay
this gives me a little relief but it's
it's not going it's not the ultimate
solution unless you're unless you're
doing it to substitute solving a problem
that you do have control over which I
don't think is what you're saying but I
think that happens sometimes but I can
because something too I think you can
you shouldn't fool yourself into
believing that it's that it's not a
symptom of a problem and it doesn't it
doesn't ultimately solve it
ironically it's a band-aid ironically we
need to wrap this up because we have to
go back to the writers room
yeah because we got in we're late I
think we told him we were gonna be there
like five minutes ago more ten minutes
ago more than that so this list list
list hit this one Justin Morgan says to
lower my stress levels I just listened
to rets massage song which that brings
me joy
and maybe it will bring you joy because
listen let's just go you want to just go
out on that you just want to go out on
the massage song I'm so tight so
stressed need someone to rub my neck
oh yeah
I like the way it works my muscle knots
with some oil on my give me a two-handed
attack I had a really hard week and I
want you to rub my feet I'm so sim so
stress these so what to rub my chest oh
yeah I like the way you work my booty
not oh man what an ending there um booty
nah you got massage is important too I
love massages I'm not gonna help you out
with that booty now no that's fine I got
somebody that works on my booty nuts the
way you rub our booty nut is using
hashtag ear biscuits to let us know
joint join the conversation with hashtag
ear biscuits thank you for all your
perspectives I'm sorry we didn't get to
that many because we just got to talking
like we do but thank you for everybody
who submitted your perspective and I
think the thing this was helpful
hopefully it was I know it was helpful
for me yeah I I feel I feel better I
mean we delayed getting his stuff we
needed to get to I mean that's all eyes
but you know what this is boy this is
this is life well that's what therapy is
man it's really just talking just
talking to somebody the best therapy
therapists just sit there with their
legs crossed and say tell me more and
that's what we did today
we told each other more yeah
[Music]